bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 nous
sommes à quelques semaines de la Coupe
du monde de football qui se tient au
Qatar et nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir Sébastien castelier et
Quentin Muller ce sont des journalistes
auteurs de les esclaves de l'homme
pétrole qui est publié chez marcely
merci à vous d'être là alors c'est un
livre qui sort au milieu d'autres de
nombreux reportages aussi sur un sujet
qui est ancien mais qui est mis en
lumière évidemment par cette Coupe du
Monde qui approche à à grands pas à
savoir les conditions de vie et de
travail de la main d'oeuvre immigrée
avant tout asiatique et africaine dans
les pays du Golfe pas seulement au
Qatar Quentin Muller c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé depuis que le Guardian a
sorti ce chiffre 6500 morts parmi les
ouvriers originaires d'Asie du Sud-Est
dans la dernière décennie est-ce que
c'est un chiffre fiable exagéré et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est un
chiffre déjà qui a eu le mérite de
d'éveiller les consciences sur les
disposition de vie des travailleurs mais
ce chiffre il est contestable pourquoi
parce que déjà sont des statistiques qui
viennent des ambassades des pays d'Asie
au Qatar seulement donc est-ce que on
peut s'y fier je ne sais pas et donc il
manque les statistiques des ambassades
des pays africains également et ce
chiffre ne prend pas en compte également
tous les travailleurs qui sont morts
quand ils sont rentrés chez eux parce
que il y a dû alors conditions de vie
sur place beaucoup meurent de problèmes
de santé important juste après leur
retour et ce chiffre là n'en tient pas
compte il y a également tous les morts
tous les travailleurs qui sont morts
pour construire le prestige et le
rayonnement international du Qatar qui a
aidé et qui a servi à la nomination du
Qatar pour pour l'obtention de la Coupe
du monde et ce chiffre n'en tient pas
compte non plus donc c'est la réalité on
est bien en dessous de la réalité alors
votre livre
que je le dise pour noter les
spectateurs il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
témoignages
au Qatar mais aussi dans les pays d'où
viennent ces travailleurs et vous
décrivez essentiellement un système
d'esclavage moderne le
Qatar s'en est offusqué évidemment
qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué le plus et
qu'est-ce qui vous fait utiliser cette
expression au combien lourde d'esclavage
pour réaliser ce livre on a pris on a
pris on a fait le choix de s'intéresser
à la situation au Qatar dans les pays du
golf mais aussi dans les pays d'origine
pour comprendre d'où viennent ces
travailleurs qu'est-ce qu'il est pousse
à partir vers les pays du Golfe et
ensuite on s'est intéressé pas seulement
à des situations individuelles mais à
comprendre un système à mettre en
lumière un système ou des travailleurs
et un nombre très important de
travailleurs construisent les pays du
Golfe avec dans certains cas un nombre
de cas assez important d'esclavagisme
moderne on parle de travailleurs qui ne
sont dans certains cas dont les
passeports sont confisqués par exemple
qui ne peuvent pas rentrer dans leur
pays tel qu'ils le souhaitent qui ne
peuvent pas changer de travail qui ne
sont dans certains cas pas payer pendant
des mois et qui n'ont pas de recours
juridique on sait donc intéressé à
comprendre le système qui est mis en
place et qui dans l'esprit est un
système d'esclavagisme moderne alors on
parle de ce système de cafala qui est en
vigueur dans beaucoup de pays du Golfe
que le Qatar a abrogé en 2020 sans doute
en réponse
critique qui fait en sorte que le
travailleur est essentiellement lié à
son employeur il lui donne son passeport
il peut pas changer d'emploi mais le
Qatar a quand même pris des pas dans la
bonne direction ce qui est pas forcément
le cas d'ailleurs des autres pays de la
région oui alors moi j'ai eu le même
doute que vous je me suis rendu dans un
premier temps quand j'étais au Qatar
dans aloité donc l'Organisation
internationale du travail qui m'a dit
peu ouprou la même chose c'est à dire
que le la CAF à la c'est terminé que il
y a une réhaus du salaire minimum etc et
donc j'ai douté et comme vous mais alors
du coup je me suis dit pour vérifier
tout ça quoi de mieux que se rendre dans
la zone industrielle donc c'est une zone
qui se retrouve qui se trouve à plus de
25 km au sud de Doha où son parcours
alors j'ai dû j'ai dû effectivement
cacher un peu ma peau blanche et me
faire passer pour un travailleur et donc
c'est il y a 400 000 travailleurs
asiatiques africains uniquement
asiatique et africains qui sont parqués
là-bas il y a pas d'occidentaux il y a
pas d'arabe qui vivent et donc je me
suis rendu dans cette zone et j'ai
demandé au travailleur est-ce que
c'était le cas et bien non c'était pas
le cas moi j'ai vu des gens qui
n'étaient plus payés depuis des mois
j'ai eu des gens qui ne pouvaient pas à
changer de travail j'ai vu des gens à
qui on avait pris le passeport j'ai vu
des gens qui avaient faim parce qu'il
n'était plus payés j'ai vu des gens qui
se qui se shootaient qui prenaient de la
drogue parce que il voulait oublier
leurs conditions de mariage j'ai vu des
gens qui n'avaient pas eu un seul jour
de congé en 9 mois de travail d'affilée
fin donc finalement je me suis dit mais
les choses n'ont pas vraiment changé
pourquoi parce que il y a
l'impossibilité d'un recours juridique
parce que sur le papier un travailleur
peut attaquer son entreprise en justice
mais encore faut-il qu'il est les fonds
pour tenir pendant des mois pour ne pas
être payé par son entreprise pour être
mis sur la touche et pour pour obtenir
gain de cause après des mois de recours
et d'attente et ça les travers n'ont pas
le temps il faut qu'ils envoient tous
les mois un salaire à leur famille pour
que leur famille puisse survivre alors
il y a le cas de Malcolm bidali qui est
un de sécurité kenyan qui a commencé à
écrire sur ces conditions de vie de
travail il a été arrêté et accusé de
propagation de désinformation il est
aujourd'hui retourné au Kenya qu'est-ce
que ça dit cela parce que c'était après
la réforme dont on a parlé l'arrestation
de Malcolm bidali and dit très long sur
la vision que le Qatar a de la question
du droit des travailleurs c'est-à-dire
que Malcolm bidali a été effectivement
en partie arrêtée parce qu'il écrivait à
des articles à la première personne et
c'est très rare pour raconter ces
conditions de vie au Qatar pour raconter
ce qu'il vivait dans son quotidien et
sur le lieu de travail également la
deuxième partie de son arrestation et la
deuxième raison pour laquelle il était
arrêté et on le sait parce qu'on l'a
rencontré on l'a interviewé au Kenya et
il nous a raconté des questions qu'il a
qui lui ont été posées et de très
nombreuses questions portaient sur
une crainte de la part des autorités de
cathari qui l'organise euh en souterrain
des syndicats qui sont interdits
aujourd'hui au Qatar et c'était
véritablement une crainte de la part des
autorités de Kadari de voir cette agent
de sécurité essayez de mettre en place
un système de prestation et c'est une
c'est une des raisons qui a conduit à
son arrestation et ça montre très bien
que le Qatar veut effectivement montrer
des réformes prendre des réformes sur le
papier tout du moins mais ne souhaite
pas donner la parole aux travailleurs
étrangers ne souhaite pas leur laisser
la liberté de s'exprimer et de raconter
ce qui leur arrive alors quand vous
voyez des appels au boycott des villes
françaises qui affirment qu'elles ne
vont pas retransmettre les matchs la
Fédération Française de Football
s'agiter quelques semaines avant vous
vous dites c'est une bonne chose parce
que finalement ça permet de pointer le
doigt sur un système que vous dénoncez
ou est-ce que vous dites c'est quand
même beaucoup d'hypocrisie parce que ça
fait des années que ça dure que ça me
concerne pas que le Qatar et que on s'en
occupe que parce que c'est la Coupe du
Monde bon moi
le débat de est-ce que c'est hypocrite
est-ce qu'il fallait pas le dire avant
etc ça c'est des débats qui sont
politiques ça m'intéresse pas moi ce que
je dis c'est que je le comprends ça
après avoir écrit ce livre après avoir
donné la parole à autant de travailleurs
abusé moi je le dis c'est cette Coupe du
Monde ce boycott les gens qui veulent le
boycotter je les comprends et je les
soutiens même si moi en tant que
journaliste j'ai pas me prononcé à me et
à dire ce qui ce qu'il faut faire si les
joueurs si les supporters doivent
boycoter ou pas mais je les comprends et
je les soutiendrai donc cette coupe du
monde là faut savoir qu'elle s'est faite
sur le sang et les larmes des
travailleurs
venus d'Asie et d'Afrique des invisibles
des gens faibles qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se défendre devant une Cour
internationale de justice et qui devrait
pourtant parce que on est sur des
volumes de de de
mort et de d'handicap qui sont qui sont
énormes et et ça on en parle on en parle
assez peu donc finalement moi je
soutiens c'est c'est ces initiatives
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va changer
quelque chose dans la gouvernance du
football mondial la FIFA ou finalement
bon bah finalement on préfère fermer les
yeux certains disent on a bien fait la
Coupe du monde dans l'Argentine des
généraux ou dans la Russie de Poutine
par exemple
est-ce que est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose au sein des instances du
football mondial c'est pas un sujet sur
lequel je suis apte à répondre je suis
pas spécialiste du foot par contre
est-ce que ça va changer quelque chose
dans les pays du Golfe au Qatar
la première chose et ce qui est
important de mentionner c'est que ça a
permis de mettre sur le devant de la
scène ces questions là ça a permis
qu'elle soit dans le débat public au
Qatar au sein des des familles catarios
sains des entreprises bien sûr bien sûr
c'est un sujet qui qui fait partie du
quotidien aussi le Qatar a été pointé du
doigt les entreprises comme les familles
effectivement parle de ce sujet après ce
que ça va changer les choses est-ce que
ça va amener des améliorations ça a
amené effectivement c'est vrai il faut
le reconnaître des améliorations sur le
papier maintenant il faut que ces
améliorations se transcrivent dans la
vraie vie et ça ça sera l'étape suivante
est-ce que le Qatar a la suite de la
Coupe du Monde fera cet effort de
continuer à aller de l'avant et essayer
effectivement de faire que les choses
s'améliorent
la réponse ce sera en 2023 merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être venu sur
le plateau de France 24 et merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cet entretien sur nos
antennes restez-y pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]